somebody I was gonna do was gonna say
this to you but somebody gave me a rock
of cocaine in Edmonton this are you
serious yeah
knowing that you were sober no they
didn't know that about me they're like a
man welcome to Canada and I opened and
I'm not afraid no no and I was like [ __ ]
you know what is it you know but he
thinks you know like I just assumed that
he things that I'm just partying or
something but he also he also just
thinks you guys became instant friends
right but the after the shows I ended up
being in my hotel room and I was picking
the dead skin off the bottom of my feet
yeah just strips of it right because I
have a left foot yeah and then I took
one piece of skin so deep that I
couldn't you know it hurt when I walk
yeah so I was like in my underworld
walking around but that's what I'm doing
I'm not doing cocaine with a bunch of
process what did you do it's a cocaine
just I gave it to another guy like an
open-mike are throw it away bro you
throw away cocaine I could if somebody
gave you cocaine like see like a
baseball cocaine Rock throw it away you
wouldn't go a Johnny come over at one of
two things I would either throw it away
or lace it with really bad poison and
then give it to someone no of course I
would throw it away you don't do drugs
never did drugs I know you well I've
smoked pot and I did mushrooms once and
it was the worst night of my life
what was it like it was so awful has
like amazing mushroom stories and no one
ever tells me the bad stuff one time I
saw my sister run naked through like a
cornfield while on shrooms and then she
thought her hands were bleeding but
thought it was like okay maybe that's
just a bad trip mine is so sad and
terrible and like all that it's like
anybody listening that thing's like I'm
gonna do true which is what happened who
are you with I was with my best friend
Paul and we were watching a bug's life
okay of course we're like let's finally
do these shrooms yeah yeah so we do the
shrooms and we're sitting there and it's
like are you feeling anything he's like
no yeah no and then eventually it was
like oh my stomach really hurts and it
was back when phones look like Nokia
like the little the ones you could play
snake on oh yeah oh that's a great game
so we each had those kinds of phones
yeah and I go I mean I gotta go lay down
in my bed yeah I got on this couch dude
so I go and I lay facedown in my bed
this isn't my old house in Valley
Village in LA today so amigo are you
okay across the house and he goes yeah I
said okay I'm gonna get on my phone and
on the timer and I want you to just
estimate when 30 seconds go by and I'll
start and he goes okay and I go go and
the whole sudden I hear stop they
stopped it was three minutes Oh minutes
it passed so then he goes okay now you
go so he starts his phone and I go go
stop three seconds I was so over trying
to get thirty seconds yeah it was I then
we've both threw up Wow and we late we
slept it off for like an hour and a half
and then never it's so sad yeah so
boring such an awful story
some people get spiritual awakening Oh
visions of God it was a new hood you did
that it was terrible
yeah awful and then I didn't do pot
until I was like 26 and I moved out here
and I was doing a play where I had to be
stoned in it and I thought okay well
I've lived enough of a life that I'm not
gonna like get hooked on pot I'm gonna
try it so at least when I'm doing this
play I know what it feels like so I can
portray being stoned accurately yeah and
then I you know I tried to get started
on smoking weed but it just never stuck
yeah
[Music]